ok neues thema mit welcher version hast
du begonnen minecraft zu spielen von die
jigs juni xj kl
schöner name hat man auch schon also den
alpha und ihr beta ich bete ende ganz
ende eifer ganz ganz ende
ich habe den account auch noch schauen
bürger mich kriegt gespielt am anfang
und dann mir aber noch in die konnte
gekauft bevor später das schicke ich
noch das video jetzt erhalte sagt der
hat ja auch irgendwann mal gesagt wenn
man sich das nicht leisten kann dann
nicht aus jemand zu dem zeitpunkt noch
kein alter das war direkt neben mir oder
so ich habe ein halbes jahr
ich kann etwas verändern wir deswegen
kein fleisch zu essen das hinter mir
explodiert ich hab noch ein halbes herz
und achte direkt unter dir
nein nicht was auf das wasser alter du
musst mir essen geben
du bist ja fahren wir runter ich darf
nicht der mir ich versuchen wir hier
unterzubringen wo bis zum dach kommt
zurück gerade eben habe ich noch den
namen gesehen ja moment die waage reisen
ich will mich nicht weg bewegen weil du
weißt hier monster und so die stars jack
ohnehin höher
aber welche stufe habt ihr die stelle
hab ich glaube mittel sind hart an
diesem hatte
aber ich glaube man bei minecraft stinke
dem ich hätte zu dem zeitpunkt noch kein
paypal
man konnte es damals nur mit paypal
kordel dich hier runter hier geht oder
mit karte und dann habe ich halt erst
recht gespielt aber dann habe ich mich
halt mich aus forderung gekümmert punkt
zu haben und dann habe ich gekauft wird
aufpassen
ja ich finde jeder wird sicher in die
runde milliarde ist das ganze doch die
hat jetzt jetzt kannst du gehen ich habe
da so ein weg runter gebaut jetzt wegen
nicht thema frauen nicht den abbauen
ganz vorsichtig den abbau nicht den
abbauen
naja ich habe als junge den armen
ich habe angst ich hab dir über ich habe
die explosion
14 gesetzt damit du dich doch
untergraben die neue überschlagen junge
du kriegst jetzt nix wenn man darin
werden wir das einfach kein vertrauen zu
mir hast ja begründet warum mache ich
sage ich erst wenn ich essen bekommen
habe bitte bitte lass es nicht einfach
hin legt einfach hin
ich brauche noch mehr ich brauchte
nein lass mich in ruhe lasst mich in
ruhe lasst mich in ruhe nicht schlagen
ich sage nein
hör auf dein ein hör auf hör auf den
verlieren wir wieder so viele level das
geht nicht wir müssen nochmal behalten
darüber entscheiden können
wir können ja mal so entscheiden und
dann battles machen aber erst noch nicht
erst mal müssen wir gut sein
oma war das treffen ab ich habe den
krieg grad schon wieder aus meiner bude
rausgeholt und die spinne ist mein haus
auch mal nein
kinderhaus förster ende haben so ist und
bilder
eine besserung wieder und geht mal ob
ich habe redstone solche zum betrieb
ich höre die haut zu tun was ist hier
los die höhle ist immens groß
ja was wir jetzt einfach nur noch nach
unten und will jemanden in der 14
ich will auch diamanten aber ich brauche
das ganze land sagt wolter ist wahr
hier ist richtig viel aber und hier so
sind so viel höher sein gegenüber in
monster rauskommt mal das komplette
wasser in die auszumachen
also ab die wellen auszumachen damit wir
und nicht 1000 wasserquellen haben ihre
suche die spinne zu motivieren dies vom
fenster aber ähnlich funktioniert es
nicht
wie ein live oder soll ein ganzes voll
von ständig versuche die spinne zu
kritisieren so wtf is all unsere
nein weil es gerade nacht war und ich
konnte ja nicht raus weil hier dieses
spinne ist jetzt hast du mich aus dem
hinterlistig angegriffen
bleibt da du bekommst malta das dort
jahre hier diese quelle zu bauen
die morgens voller gefühle und sporne
gefunden ich bin ich hab fast bis nach
oben geschoben um diese blöde
wasserquelle zuzumachen däne hat einen
spanner gefunden den reiter weise ich
organisiere michael sozial mache für die
sequel zu damit du hier sachen findest
danke ich danke auch ein bisschen
diamanten für das kind ist es einen
appell halben und ich habe mein kopf
bargeld gefunden jetzt realisiere ich
hier gerade warum hier eine quelle ist
und zwar eine soziale und herr mehr
alles umsonst gemacht
zombies wo hast du wieder zum gedenken
kommt hier durch never ever
halberstadt fbo oder was die kalkbrenner
nein nein alles wird gut ansieht geholt
ich nehme ein bisschen mo stein mit für
so dekorations klick und man könnte hier
auch eine expedition 22 9 uhr durch
bisschen krumm graben 9 wenn wir das
höchste entscheidend ist der wille ist
30 muss auch viel mehr fahren auf jeden
fall erstmal der spitze und ja aber ich
meine ohne mich jetzt besonders auf xp
zu bekommen zu konzentrieren habe ich zu
dieser neuen bekommen was angeblich
haben einfach
naja eben und dann braucht man keine
gesonderte xp fahren eigentlich so
wirklich noch nicht aber ich habe einen
spanner gefunden wird zum teil und sowas
aber nicht schlecht ich merke immer hier
die koordinaten -20 also eigentlich bei
null ungefähr und dann ruhe eigentlich
bei null und z ist - 30 also ist doch
eben den chat und danach eingestellt 30
aber ich vertraue auf das ihr euch das
in die kommentare schreibt dass ihr euch
das eine in die kommentare schreibt
merkt euch das und wenn wir so 120
folgen wieder dann hier sind dann sagt
er da und da aber doch ins bonner da
könnt ihr doch die spd verlieren machen
ich will mich nicht auf die zuschauer
verlassen du diesem foul
diese sind cool meines erachtens das
bereich oder an das war ganz schlecht
selbst alle jetzt alle in die kommentare
schreiben konkreter als doof aber der
bitte von crafter zitat jetzt so witte
konkreter ist der hof und dann klatsch
klatsch mit sternchen dabei so stellen
von peter stützer denn damit auch in
stressigen news hast du mehr von solchen
geschichten
hey you can say the jacks nachmachen
spitzhacke kaputt und es hat mich so
geht's nicht
skelett wechseln keine blaue augen
seines teams und wenn's ausgeleuchtet
ist war ja eigentlich ausgeleuchtet aber
somehow dachte der sich schon mal ich
hab nichts geschafft er gar nix wird es
doch so ein haus ist das komplett weg
explodiert so explodiert nie weg
implodiert
da hätte sie mit im studio partnerin
gefahren beim formel 1 da ist er auch
sehr plötzlich sowohl riesen explosion
vor mir nur ein paar autos ineinander
gekracht habe ich gesehen hab ich
gedreht
ja ich gucke die video from pain nutzer
empfehlen dass let's play von dem was
ich glaub ich mich damit das spiel auch
er ja mal mussten die kommentare
geschrieben dass ich nur falls play
gesehen haben spielen das zeigt mal
wieder was durch let's play möglich ist
minecraft ja auch nicht so ein erfolg
gewesen ohne deren er ist richtig hatte
das lebt davon dass es halt jetzt immer
wieder so hochgepusht wird in
anführungszeichen youtube sonst wäre das
nie mit 1 er das erst also nicht das
erste spiel minecraft hat aber den let's
play halb erst so richtig ausgelöst
davor gab es auch er aber nichts zwar
auch nur annähernd so erfolgreich wie
heutzutage muss einmal durch die ganzen
minecraft displays von die oscars im
englischen bereich zum beispiel oder
deutschland der kontrast extrem a1
extrem leicht krank die boj sorger und
schreibe lapislazuli gefunden und gold
und redstone alles kommt mittlerweile
eigentlich gar nicht mehr so toll finde
naja startet oder ja aber ich fand ihn
ja da war ich noch vertieft hat aber
mittlerweile finde ich irgendwie gucke
ich voll wenig ich gar nicht ich habe
dann auch noch nie geguckt mich lange
nicht so ganz am anfang geschaut als es
neu war habe ich echt die folgen ich
hatte nach zehn folgen oder ungefähr so
habe ich bin ich eingestiegen habe sie
alle an zwei tagen geschaut
ich hätte mir immer aufs handy gemachten
auf dem schulweg im bus geschaut und
dann habe ich sie mir jeden tag wirklich
jeden tag und dann habe ich irgendwann
mal folge 80 oder so auf gehört ist klar
denn ihr daniel guck mal hier dies für
mich ja kannst du mir sticks geben oder
ganz viele fackeln ich habe der essen
gegeben wurde
also das ist jetzt aber drohen ich
wollte es dir geben aber wenn du so
kommst dann nicht ist mir was schuldig
eine frau ist okay forscher
wo bist du jetzt hier ja dabei meistens
einfach da zu meinem offen
helmut ist wo ist da stand ich habe
angst dass ihr lover ist also für ganzen
verschwenderisch fackel fackel fackel
hier stimmt ist ein alter hier aber ich
hab selber muss auch ein bisschen
haushalten jetzt ich lass mir jetzt
gegeben
holz für holz ist nicht verarschen
das sind nur nicht die kohle allgemeine
kohle wieder ja die quote kannst du
haben da hatte dachte schon du brauchst
doch nur für fackeln brauchst du das
holz aus dem holz ganz lustig machen
ja hab ich noch mehr als ich habe gar
nichts hier mache ist mir du bekommst
vier fackeln raus was auch schon steckt
damit was ich dir gegeben habe aber ich
hab selber jetzt leider auch nichts mehr
ich habe mir selber gemacht ich hätte
mir holz nicht nehmen sollen
meerholz auch nochmals die fakten hier
immerhin wird sparsam nennt man so was
elternhaus sieht das richtig geil aus
denn was du da gemacht so was nicht
gemacht
ich habe das gemacht was hast du gemacht
das ganze haus das fahrrad hat er
kakteen nicht gut an ich runter von hier
ist lass mich jetzt ruft man doch doch
das sehr gute arbeit leiste ist ein 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 beinkraft in steppen gesagt
diese war
text was ganz böses bh von teufeln und
sowas war wusstet ihr dass das dass
parasiten abtötet was zeigt junge ja ich
bin ein beziehungs typ nicht ab sondern
verstärkt das immunsystem wieder so dass
du viel resistenter gegen was man unter
hatte sperma tiefe stimme bekommt also
wenn mädels etwas eine tiefe strege alt
müsste nicht näher erläutert werden
das haben sie bei galileo gezeigt ich
habe komplett mir dass etliche party
look ja weißt du was
warum er warf nein mama hat gesagt ich
soll fremden leuten nicht zu hören also
halt stopp rede ich ja das sowieso so
jetzt kann das wasser immer weg alter
ich hasse das wenn ich weiß wo das ganze
wasser herkommt
hier ist so riesig überall wasser junge
ich bin hier nur bei lava und eigentlich
ist bei lava die chance mit am größten
und ich bin auch auf höhe 11 das ist
perfekt der höhe für so diamanten
unseren zeugs und ich finde einfach nix
oder wenigstens mein emerald oder irgend
sowas ja invasion ihren ist
wahrscheinlich gibt es in der welt lockt
auch wenn man wieder so eine dings sind
dass lime bin ich glaube wir sind klein
gestorben warum weiß nicht ob zwei freie
bälle
das ist auch dort also können sie nicht
von dir sein
außerdem hatten wir in philosophie was
rechteübertragung und sowas von sachen
und der über lava wenn man sachen findet
dann darf man es begann zu regnen
ich bin direkt neben dir ja auch gerade
und bist du auch eisenteile wo kommst du
her
ja ich war hierbei der lava bin ich
sogar überbaut und dachte so dass egal
sagt ja man ist in einer und dann nur so
so muss das sein
wow zu den wegebau bogner hat sich so
von alleine generiert nexans ist das
erklärt natürlich alles irgendwie so
monstermäßig irgendwo so unterwegs oder
warum es hier so ab der infizierung ja
irgendwo die apachen 1 gefunden
irgendwie oder